CORONAVIRUS CRISIS.
WE ARE TOLD THE TAPE PLAY OUT IS
NOT READY, DROP ON IN.
>> President Trump: AND WE
WILL DO IT.
I THOUGHT WHAT I MIGHT DO IS GO
AROUND THE ROOM AND INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES REALLY QUICKLY AND
THEN HAVE A DISCUSSION
AFTERWARDS.
AND THEN, THAT INCLUDES
PRIVILEGES TO DEDUCT THE LOSSES
THIS YEAR HOPEFULLY WE WILL BE
BACK IN BUSINESS VERY SOON, THIS
COUNTRY WASN’T BUILT TO BE
CLOSED.
AND, SINCE WE HAVE A CLOSED
COUNTRY, NOBODY HAS EVER HEARD
OF A THING LIKE THIS.
BUT THIS WAS WITH SOME OF THE
LEADING PROFESSIONALS AND THEY
SAY, NOT SINCE 1917 HAS THERE
BEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
1917 WAS A TIME WHERE I GUESS
YOU COULD SAY, THERE WERE
ESTIMATES OF PEOPLE WHO DIED.
THINK OF THAT, AT 100 MILLION,
100 MILLION PEOPLE DIED SO THEY
HAD NO COMMUNICATIONS AND
WEREN’T ABLE TO SHUT THINGS DOWN
THAT WE ARE DOING.
THAT WAS A PLAGUE.
IT STARTED HERE ACTUALLY, WE
WERE BADLY AFFECTED BUT EUROPE
WAS REALLY AFFECTED.
SO THAT WAS THE WORST.
NOT SINCE 100 YEARS AGO, MORE
THAN A HUNDRED YEARS AGO THIS
HAPPENED.
I KNOW ALL OF YOU BY SEEING ALL
THE COVERS OF THE BUSINESS
MAGAZINES AND THE MAGAZINES,
YOU’VE DONE A GREAT JOB AND WE
WILL WORK THIS ON.
IT’S A GREAT BUSINESS AND A VERY
VIABLE BUSINESS.
HONESTLY YOU’VE BEEN VERY FAIR.
YOU KEPT ENERGY PRICES, MAYBE WE
WILL START WITH MIKE.
>> MICHAEL BOYD, PROUD OF THE
WORK YOUR PEOPLE ARE DOING TO
SUPPORT HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS,
FIRST RESPONDERS AND ALL THE
OTHER VITAL INDUSTRIES THAT KEEP
OUR ECONOMY GOING.
THANK YOU.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
BE HERE TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOU ARE DOING FOR US.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>> DAVE HAGER, INDEPENDENT OIL
AND GAS COMPANY OUT OF
OKLAHOMA CITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
LEADERSHIP YOU ARE PROVIDING
DURING THIS CHALLENGING TIME.
YOU ARE THE MUCH RIGHT MAN AT
THE RIGHT TIME TO BALANCE
PRIORITIES, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> President Trump: WE WILL
GET IT DONE.
>> GREG DARLING.
THANK YOU FOR THE GREAT
LEADERSHIP IN THIS PANDEMIC PIPE
CRISIS AND THE STIMULUS PACKAGE,
REALLY FOR THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
AND FROM EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
WORKING FOR ENERGY.
>> President Trump: WE THINK
IT WILL COME BACK QUICKLY.
IT’S READY AND WE HAVE THE RIGHT
PACKAGES OUT THERE.
WE ARE LOOKING AT, I THINK WE
ARE LOOKING VERY SERIOUSLY AT AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE WHERE
IT’S SO IMPORTANT FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
AS OF THIS MOMENT, WE HAVE
7 TRILLION PLUS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
AND FOR WHAT REASON?
AND WE DON’T PUT MONEY IN OUR
OWN COUNTRY.
SO WE ARE GOING TO DO A BIG
PACKAGE ON INFRASTRUCTURE FAIRLY
SOON I THINK, AND THAT’S VERY
IMPORTANT.
GREAT FOR YOU AND GREAT FOR
EVERYBODY.
>> PRESIDENT, I’D LIKE TO ADD MY
THANKS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS SPACE AS WELL AND I THINK
ALL OF OUR COMPANIES ARE
ALIGNING WITH YOUR OBJECTIVE
WHICH IS TO GET THE ECONOMY
MOVING AND MAKE LIVES AROUND THE
WORLD BETTER.
>> I’M THE CHAIRMAN OF
CONTINENTAL RESOURCES OUT OF
OKLAHOMA CITY.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
MEETING.
I THINK IT’S SO TIMELY AND
NECESSARY.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
ALSO THE FRIENDSHIP YOU KEPT
WITH THE SAUDIS, THE SAUDI
PRIME MINISTER AND CROWN
PRINCE AND ALSO AND ALSO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
I KNOW THOSE HAVEN’T BEEN EASY
SOMETIMES BUT AT THIS TIME IT
WAS PARTICULARLY NEEDED.
SO I REPRESENT, AND THAT IS THE
DOMESTIC PRODUCERS ALLIANCE, AND
WE ARE AT ABOUT 10,000 COMPANIES
AND INDIVIDUALS.
>> President Trump: THAT’S A
GREAT JOB YOU ARE DOING.
IF PRESIDENT PUTIN AND THE CROWN
PRINCE WANT SOMETHING TO HAPPEN
BADLY, I’VE SPOKEN TO BOTH OF
THEM.
WE WILL TELL YOU ABOUT THAT IN A
LITTLE WHILE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, JEFF
HILDENBRAND.
OUR POSITION IS WE ARE THE ONLY
PRIVATE COMPANY HERE.
THIS IS A COMPANY THAT IS BASED
IN HOUSTON, DOMESTIC ONLY
EXPIRATION A PRODUCTION COMPANY
AND I’M REALLY HERE TODAY TO
REPRESENT THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
COMPANIES.
THE FAMILY-OWNED BUSINESSES THAT
ARE IN THIS INDUSTRY.
AND TO GIVE YOU THAT PERSPECTIVE
AND ADD TO THE CONVERSATION IN
THAT REGARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP, I
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU MR. PRESIDENT,
KELSEY WARREN, ENERGY TRANSFER.
WE TRY TO DO BUSINESS WITH
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM AND I
THINK WE SUCCESSFULLY DO,
ACTUALLY.
IT’S AN HONOR TO BE HERE, SIR,
AND AN HONOR TO BE IN THIS ROOM
WITH THESE FOLKS AS WELL.
>> President Trump: AND
>> President Trump: HE’S NOT
AN OIL OR GAS MAN, HE IS A
WONDERFUL PERSON AND A WONDERFUL
POLITICIAN AND HE WANTS TO SEE
THE INDUSTRY GET STRONG AGAIN.
SO KEVIN, DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
TO SAY?
>> FIRST, BY YOU REACHING OUT TO
PRESIDENT PUTIN AND AND A CROWN
PRINCE, THINGS HAVE IMPROVED.
YOU WERE LOOKING A LOT OF JOBS,
A LOT OF THESE ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WORK WITH ALL
THESE INDIVIDUALS AROUND HERE,
YOUR ACTION TODAY, GETTING THE
SMALL BUSINESS LOANS OUT IS
GOING VERY STRONGLY BECAUSE IT
IS NEEDED.
BUT, THE AMERICAN ECONOMY’S
GREATEST STRENGTH IS WHAT ENERGY
PROVIDES US.
THESE ARE GREAT JOBS, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, IT GIVES US ENERGY,
IT CHANGES THE WHOLE DYNAMICS
AROUND THE WORLD, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LARGER SHIP.
>> President Trump: AS YOU
JUST SAID, BANK OF AMERICA IN
PARTICULAR HAS REALLY STEPPED
IN, THEY HAVE DONE A FANTASTIC
JOB TODAY.
BANK OF AMERICA HAS BEEN
UNBELIEVABLE.
I WANT TO THANK THEM, I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE COMMUNITY BANKS
AND THE SMALLER BANKS THAT HAVE
BEEN LOANING A LOT OF MONEY, IT
IS ALL ABOUT THE PAYCHECK.
NOBODY BELIEVED IT WOULD’VE GONE
SO WELL.
IT’S JUST A NUMBER OF HOURS, BUT
THE NUMBERS ARE FAR GREATER THAN
WE WOULD’VE ANTICIPATED.
IT HAS BEEN REALLY GREAT,
THANK YOU TO ALL THE BANKS.
AGAIN, IN PARTICULAR,
BANK OF AMERICA, THEY REALLY
STEPPED RIGHT UP.
THERE WERE NO BIG DEALS, THEY
WEREN’T MAKING A BIG DEAL OUT OF
ANYTHING.
THAT WAS TERRIFIC.
I THINK WHAT WE WANT TO DO, JOHN
GORMAN, PLEASE, I KNOW HOW YOU
ARE SO INVOLVED IN THIS, FROM
THE GREAT STATE OF TEXAS, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SAY COUPLE OF WORDS
HERE?
>> THANK YOU MR. PRESIDENT,
THANK YOU FOR CONVENING A
MEETING, MANY OF US HAVE BEEN
TALKING TOGETHER, BUT WE CAN’T
GET DONE WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE,
ONLY YOU AND THE ADMINISTRATION
CAN, PARTICULARLY, GETTING THE
ATTENTION OF THE SAUDIS AND
FLOODING THE MARKET IS REALLY
ADDING INSULT TO INJURY AT A
TIME WHEN OUR COMMERCE IS
SUFFERING ANYWAY BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THIS MEETING COULD NOT BE MORE
TIMELY.
I AGREE WITH WHAT’S BEEN SAID
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
AFFORDABLE ENERGY TO OUR
STANDARD OF LIVING.
REALLY, WE HAVE CHANGED THE
WORLD AS A RESULT OF THE
PRODUCTION OF DOMESTIC ENERGY
HERE AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
JOHN AGREES, WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT IT THE OTHER DAY, YOU HAVE
ALL DONE WELL, YOU HAVE ALSO
KEPT ENERGY VERY AFFORDABLE.
VERY, VERY AFFORDABLE.
A LOT OF IT.
WE HAVE NOT HAD ANY PROBLEMS, DO
I SEE DAN BACK THERE?
I WAS LOOKING, I THOUGHT THAT
LOOKED LIKE DAN.
>> I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING THIS MEETING, YOU
KNOW, UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, WORKING WITH THE
CONGRESS, THE U.S. HAS BECOME
THE WORLD’S ENERGY SUPERPOWER
AGAIN.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
THESE COMPANIES HAVE DONE IT,
OBVIOUSLY IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE IN MY STATE, THE GREAT
STATE OF ALASKA.
BUT THESE ARE GREAT JOBS, AS
JOHN JUST SAID, FOR ALL OF OUR
STATES.
BUT IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THE NATIONAL SECURITY OF OUR
COUNTRY TWO.
WE HAVE BEEN, A NUMBER OF
SENATORS HAVE BEEN REACHING OUT,
HAVING FRANK DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE SAUDIS SAYING HEY, IF YOU
ARE A LONG-STANDING ALLY OF
OURS, RIGHT NOW, YOU ARE HURTING
A LOT OF OUR CITIZENS, YOU ARE
HURTING A LOT OF PEOPLE WE
REPRESENT AND IT SHOULDN’T TAKE
US FOR GRANTED.
WE HAVE A GREAT MILITARY, THAT
HAS PROTECTED SAUDI ARABIA FOR
DECADES, AND IT SENATOR CRAMER
AND I HAVE SOME LEGISLATION THAT
COULD POSSIBLY CHANGE THAT IF
THEY DON’T START TO COOPERATE.
SO AGAIN, WE APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP WITH THE CROWN
PRINCE, WITH THE RUSSIANS, AND
CALLING THIS MEETING.
BUT THIS IS A GREAT SECTOR OF
THE U.S. ECONOMY, ONCE WE GET
THROUGH THIS, AND WE WILL, THIS
PANDEMIC, THIS SECTOR IS GOING
TO TAKE OFF AGAIN.
YOU ARE ADMINISTRATION, AND YOU
HAVE HAD A LOT TO DO WITH THE
U.S. ENERGY SECTOR, AND WE NEED
TO KEEP IT STRONG.
>> President Trump: AND KEVIN
CRAMER, NOTE THAT CARLA, PEOPLE
DON’T REALIZE HOW BIG OF A
PRODUCER NORTH DAKOTA IS, RIGHT?
>> MR. PRESIDENT, TO ECHO
EVERYTHING, PEOPLE AROUND YOUR
CONFERENCE TABLE RIGHT NOW, WE
ARE A PART OF THE RENAISSANCE OF
OIL AND GAS IN THIS COUNTRY.
SINCE YOU BECAME PRESIDENT, WE
WENT FROM A RENAISSANCE TO
SECURITY TO INDEPENDENTS TO
DOMINANCE.
THAT DOMINANCE AND THAT SECURITY
RIGHT NOW ARE IN SOME DANGER,
JUST A QUICK EXAMPLE, RIGHT NOW
IN NORTH DAKOTA, SINCE
SAUDI ARABIA AND RUSSIA
ANNOUNCED, WE HAVE $6 BILLION
TAKEN OUT OF OUR STATE THIS YEAR
YEAR.
THE ENTIRE GROSS DOMESTIC
PRODUCT OF NORTH DAKOTA IS
$13 BILLION.
THAT IS SIGNIFICANT, THAT
REPRESENTS LOTS OF JOBS, LOTS OF
PEOPLE IN THE VALUE CHAIN.
JUST ONE WORD TO WHAT DAN TALKED
ABOUT WITH REGARD TO
SAUDI ARABIA.
IT IS ESTIMATED, BY ONE REPORT
IN 2018 THAT WE SPEND A MINIMUM
OF $81 BILLION DEFENDING GLOBAL
OIL SUPPLIES.
WE USE THAT MONEY AND OTHER
HOT SPOTS IN THE WORLD IF OUR
FRIENDS ARE GOING TO TREAT US
THIS WAY.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR OUTREACH,
JUST WITH THE SUCCESS OF YOUR
DIPLOMACY THIS WEEK.
>> President Trump: IT HAS
GONE UP, WE HAVE TO, OTHERWISE
WE DO LOSE A LOT OF JOBS.
WERE TALKING ABOUT ONE OF THE
BIG JOB PRODUCERS ANYWAY, KEVIN,
RIGHT?
WOULD YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO SAY?
>> MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU,
PRESIDENT OF THE
AMERICAN PETROLEUM INSTITUTE,
THE FOLKS AROUND THIS TABLE
REPRESENT THE AMERICAN ENERGY
REVOLUTION.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU HAVE DONE TO
SUPPORT THAT REVOLUTION AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
REVOLUTION CONTINUES AFTER THIS
PANDEMIC CRISIS IS RESOLVED.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU.
WHERE IS THE SENATOR CRUZ?
HE HAS GONE OVER TO THE EVIL
SIDE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MEETING AS
YOU KNOW IN A TIME OF CROSSES
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND AN
ECONOMIC CRISIS, AS YOU HEARD
AND AS YOU KNOW FROM EVERYONE
AROUND THIS TABLE, THE ENERGY
SECTOR HAS BEEN A HUGE PART OF
THE ECONOMIC SUCCESS AND BOOM
THAT WE HAVE ENJOYED OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
THE COMBINATION OF THE ECONOMIC
HARM OF THE CORONAVIRUS CRISIS
COMBINED WITH THE SAUDIS AND
RUSSIANS WAGING ECONOMIC WARFARE
ON JOBS IN THIS COUNTRY HAS BEEN
A PERFECT STORM IN THE ENERGY
SECTOR.
I WILL TELL YOU, THERE ARE A LOT
OF JOBS, MILLIONS OF JOBS IN
TEXAS AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT ARE REPRESENTED BY THE MEN
AND WOMEN AROUND THIS TABLE AND
BY ENERGY PRODUCERS AND THERE
ARE SMALL PRODUCERS THROUGHOUT
TEXAS, THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
WHO ARE ON THE VERGE OF BEING
DRIVEN OUT OF BUSINESS.
AND SO THIS MEETING, I THINK IS
IMPORTANT.
EVERY ONE OF THE SENATORS IN
THIS ROOM HAS HAD MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SAUDIS
LEADING AND HARD ON THE SAUDIS,
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
DIPLOMACY WITH THE CROWN PRINCE
HAVE A BIG IMPACT GETTING THEM
TO STOP FLOODING THE MARKET AND
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS CRISIS
AND I WOULD UNDERSCORE ONE OTHER
ISSUE THAT A NUMBER OF THE FOCUS
AROUND THIS TABLE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
ENSURING THOSE IN ENERGY AND
THIS TIME OF CRISIS HAVE ACCESS
TO CAPITAL.
THERE ARE JOBS THAT ARE HANGING
IN THE BALANCE AND THE ENERGY
PRODUCERS IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
HAVE MADE AMERICA THE NUMBER ONE
PRODUCER OF OIL AND GAS IN THE
WORLD CAN ACCESS CAPITAL TO GET
OUT OF THIS CRISIS, WE ARE GOING
TO SEE BANKRUPTCY AT A LEVEL
THIS COUNTRY HASN’T SEEN IN
DECADES.
SO, THIS MEETING AND CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP OF YOUR
ADMINISTRATION IS HUGELY
IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR.
WHILE YOU ARE UP, THE CONCEPT, I
THINK WE SHOULD SAY IT IN THE
MEETING, WHILE RESERVES, STORING
OIL, FILLING UP THE NATIONAL
RESERVES, AS YOU KNOW.
YET THESE PRICES, KEVIN AND I
HAVE BEEN SPEAKING ABOUT IT, AT
THESE PRICES, YOU WOULD THINK HE
WOULD WANT TO FILL UP EVERY
CABIN THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND THE SAMARIAN’S IN
LOUISIANA AND OTHER AREAS THAT
COULD BE FELT UP TO HOLD A LOT
OF OIL.
THEY WILL KEEP EVERYBODY WORKING
WORKING, YOU WOULD WANT TO FILL
UP THOSE AREAS, WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT, TIED?
>> I THINK THAT IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
I THINK IT MAKES SENSE IN TERMS
OF EASING THE PRESSURE IN TERMS
OF THREATENING THESE JOBS.
THAT IS THE STRATEGIC PETROLEUM
RESERVE IS THERE FOR A TIME OF
CRISIS.
USUALLY, THE WAY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WORKS AS WE BUY WHEN
IT’S EXPENSIVE AND WE SELL WHEN
IT’S CHEAP.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
NOW TO BUY WHEN IT’S CHEAP, I
THINK IT WAS INEXCUSABLE THAT
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP IN THE
HOUSE AND SENATE BLOCKED THAT IN
THE BILL WE PASSED LAST WEEK,
AND I THINK CONGRESS NEEDS TO GO
BACK AND ADDRESS IT.
>> IT WAS IN THE BILL, THE
SPEAKER CAME IN, THAT THE ONE
THING, WHEN SHE HELD THIS BILL
UP FOR A NUMBER OF DAYS THAT YOU
REMOVE.
>> THERE ARE TOO MANY DEMOCRATS
I WANT TO SEE JOBS GO.
>> President Trump: I THINK
YOU SHOULD GO BACK THERE KEVIN,
YOU SHOULD GO BACK THERE, IF YOU
GUYS COULD GO BACK AND DO A
SEPARATE BILL.
BEYOND THAT, I THINK
75 MILLION BARRELS RIGHT NOW,
THAT’S NOT THAT MUCH.
WERE STILL IN PRETTY GOOD SHAPE,
BUT WE HAVE OTHER AREAS THAT ARE
BIGGER, FRANKLY, BUT WE SHOULD
BE PUMPING IT OUT.
MAYBE YOU GUYS CAN TRACK HONESTY
WE CAN DO.
I DON’T THINK ANYONE CAN REJECT
IT.
NOBODY CAN REJECT IT, TODD.
ANYBODY ELSE?
YOU GUYS OKAY?
>> JUST ONE THING,
MR. PRESIDENT , THE DEPARTMENT O
THE INTERIOR MANAGES A LARGE
PORTION, ONE OF THE THINGS WE’VE
DONE OVER THE LAST 15 DAYS TO
SLOW THE SPREAD, WE HAVE REALLY
HAD OUR SPECTERS OUT ON THE
FRONT LINES WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT PRODUCTION IS TAKING PLACE
I THINK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
COOPERATION IN THAT.
THESE JOBS ARE SO IMPORTANT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND IT’S
IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE DOUBT OUR EYES AND CROSS OUR
TEAMS TO.
>> President Trump: THE
BIGGEST LAND MINE IN THE
COUNTRY.
MEANING THE INTERIOR, IT’S A LOT
OF LAND WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT.
THANK YOU, GREAT JOB YOU ARE
DOING.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP, I’M IN THE
SECRETARY OF ENERGY
30 MILLION BARRELS,
NOTWITHSTANDING THE DESIRE OF
CONGRESS NOT TO GIVE US MONEY TO
PURSUE THIS IDEA.
WE HAVE FOUND AN ALTERNATIVE
FINANCING MECHANISM.
>> President Trump: I FIGURED
HE WOULD.
I WASN’T WORRIED ABOUT IT.
WHAT ARE YOU PAYING PER BARREL?
A FLEXIBLE PRAISE?
WERE GOING TO GO NEGATIVE, LIKE
INTEREST?
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I WANTED TO
KNOW FOR THE INDUSTRY THAT’S
HERE WE HAVE, AT THE U.S.
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY NOT ONLY TO
PROVIDE IMMEDIATELY RELIEF FOR
THIS PARTICULAR INDUSTRY IN THE
ECONOMY ITSELF BUT ALSO FOR
TECHNOLOGY THAT OVER TIME THE
CROSS STRUCTURE OF THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
>> President Trump: CHECK OUT
OTHER AREAS WHERE YOU CAN STORE
OIL.
THERE ARE SOME VERY BIG ONES,
BIGGER THAN WHAT WE HAVE NOW.
AT THESE PRICES, YOU SHOULD DO
IT.
FILL IT UP, RIGHT?
FILL UP THE TANK.
OKAY, YOU’VE BEEN SO GREAT, SOME
OF THE BEST TRADE DEALS EVER
DONE IN OUR COUNTRY.
ONE OF THEM WAS ACTUALLY KICKED
ON APRIL 1ST, THAT’S WITH CHINA,
I HOPE THEY ARE BUYING A LOT, I
HOPE.
>> OUT ASKING A QUESTION,
MR. PRESIDENT .
THE TRADE DEALS ARE WORKING, WE
ARE ON TRACK.
>> President Trump: HE JUST
WANTS TO MAKE DEALS, THAT’S ALL.
WE’VE DONE A GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL HAVE A NEWS CONFERENCE
AT ABOUT 5:00, 5:15 MAY BE.
WE WILL SEE YOU IN A LITTLE
WHILE, WE WILL ANSWER QUESTIONS,
THIS IS A GREAT GROUP OF
LEADERS.
WE’VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PRESERVE AND EVEN MAKING GREATER
OUR ENERGY INDUSTRY.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
SENATORS AND CONGRESS MAN, THE
BOSS HERE FOR BEING HERE AND
WORKING SO HARD.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT THEY ARE
CALLING ME CONSTANTLY, THEY WANT
YOU OR INDUSTRY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
THEY’RE GOING TO MAKE IT THAT
WAY.
WE ARE ALL GOING TO MAKE IT THAT
I WILL SEE YOU AT 5:00, SAME
PLACE, WE LOOK FORWARD TO IT.
THANK YOU.
WOULD ANYBODY LIKE TO BE TESTED?
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE TESTED?
>> I WOULD LOVE TO BE TESTED.
I THINK ALL OF US WOULD.
>> President Trump: YOU KNOW
WHAT, I LIKE IT, LET’S TEST
THESE GUYS.
MILLIONS OF JOBS, LISTEN, THEY
GAVE US MILLIONS OF JOBS,
ANYBODY WANTS TO BE TESTED, WE
WILL TEST THEM.
I WANT TO TEST THE HEAD OF EXXON
EXXON.